we have a national epidemic on gun
violence in America that was Atlanta
mayor Andre Dickens shortly after 24
year old shooting suspect Dion Patterson
was arrested in neighboring Cobb County
Wednesday it was around eight hours
earlier than the first 9-1-1 calls came
in he was shot she seriously believing
the law enforcement source told CBS News
at Patterson a Coast Guard veteran was
in a waiting room in the Northside
Hospital medical facility when he became
agitated taking out a handgun opening
fire fleeing the scene and police say
carjacking a pickup truck from a nearby
gas station we didn't know what the
poppy noise was so originally we just
ignored it gate Jake Johnson was two
floors below the shooter when gunfire
rang out all five victims were women one
CDC employee Amy Saint Pierre died
authorities say the other four were
hospitalized